- Mmm. That was really good.
(cough)
I'm trying to convince my
brain not to kill myself.
(western music)
- [Man in plaid shirt] What
the (swear) is nutraloaf?
- Nobody knows.
- Sounds like something healthy though,
that they'd sell at weight-watchers.
(western music)
- [Woman's voice] Kind of weird that
they, like, punish you
with food in prison.
That seems very juvenile.
- This one's highly odorous.
- It smells like my dogs food.
- It smells like --
- Nope. I don't like this one.
- I would not survive in prison.
- It's alright.
- It was like old,
leathery meat with glue.
- I don't think this is food.
- There's like a lack of human respect
with this that really bothers me.
- Yeah.
- I'd be so furious if
they were giving me this.
Like it would make me even madder.
- [Red-haired man] This
one looks real bad.
It looks real bad or
just like carrot cake.
- It smells like the trash
at an Italian food place.
- Cheers.
- This is so depressing.
- Ugh.
- I like this one the best yet.
- I'm not as afraid of this food.
- I'm not swallowing this.
- It's very garlic-y.
- If this is your every freakin' day,
for like multiple meals a
day, that's kinda messed up.
- This is definitely punishment food.
- This is basically the
equivalent of starving people
because, who would eat this?
- I feel like I'm depressed
now, after eating this.
- [Bald man] I feel like I'm
about to eat someone's vomit.
Like I feel like I'm about to...
go to the bar where someone
threw up on the ground,
and I'm gonna scoop it into my mouth.
- The taste is okay, the
texture is all over the place.
- Why is there raisins in this?
What kind of (swear) person are you?
- Eh, it's like mildly better.
- I'm chewing a lot, but
I'm not getting any flavor.
- Because it's punishment.
You're not supposed to
be getting any flavor.
- Not I take it back, the
taste is the same as before,
just slightly different
kinds of unappetizing.
- I don't know what good
food tastes like anymore.
(western music)